Julie I know you have always talked
about with this show you want to go out
on your own terms you want to be able to
craft the story how you want to do it
and really put an ending on this at this
point in the series have you picked your
ending yeah absolutely you know the
greatest honor you can have as a
storyteller in a business of television
is to be able to make those decisions
with your peers and with your friends
and with your fellow storytellers and we
all have discussed it and we've made the
decision that this is it and you guys
are here for our last comic-con because
this is going to be the final season of
the Vampire Diaries yeah
and it's a bittersweet and emotional and
we're all going to be crying
but we wanted to be once tell you guys
first because you've been with us all on
this run
and
grateful to you and the fans all around
the world obviously but the Comic Con
fans who are here with us before meeting
and air you know that some of the people
who are laughing screaming because they
thought they were there for my day with
me monster trucks or something and you
guys stuck with this and you came out
and you've been with us all so we made
you something
and you guys are the ones that get just
ain't here first so we're gonna thank
you
do we love you
you